getting into data science and machine
learning can be intimidating you have to
label the data train the model see if it
all works fine tune and then keep
repeating those steps to keep the model
continuously relevant that's a lot so
today i invited carlos zanchia ceo of
plainside a machine learning and ai
company that makes vision ai accessible
with no code welcome carlos and thanks
for joining me today hi priyanka thanks
a lot it's always a pleasure to join and
uh always ready to talk and chat a
little bit about plain sight and how we
can help everyone better understand and
utilize ai solutions okay so with that
what is plain sight as a company plain
sight aims to democratize ai and enable
business users in all sectors to build
complete and operationalized vision ai
solutions
there are more than 3.2 billion images
and 720 000 hours of video created every
day
this explosion of visual data has
accelerated the growth and adoption of
computer vision
it's a way for computers to see more of
the world with an unblinking consistency
and a far greater accuracy
the plain sight no code ai platform
makes it easier and faster to derive
value from highly accurate and
customized vision ai solutions
throughout an organization or business
or business and enterprises allowing
automation predictions and insight into
previously unseen data well that is
pretty powerful and it makes it really
easy for literally anyone to use ai in
their workflow but if i'm a user of
plain sight now let's say i have a
project where i'm looking to use
computer vision and i have some images
and i need to build a model what do i
need to do so we really take those uh
images and create a data source from
them and it's either images or video
and that
raw data set is where we now need to
collect it and put it into the cloud
at that point we're creating a version
and
we need to provide some context and
create some sort of labels around what
you'd like the machine to learn from
these images and to do that we annotate
the video or label the video with the
specific context that's required
and that labeling is done through our ai
assisted features that we have on the
platform that enable users to
go much faster through the labeling
process you can imagine a small data set
doesn't take a long time to go through
but as the data set gets larger and
larger these ai assisted features really
help and decrease the time it takes to
provide that sort of context to the
model
now that we have a model that's
ready for training we take that schema
or definition of what we want to provide
the model during training and
build our custom container and we'll
talk a little bit about the custom
container in a bit but this is where
we're actually deploying within the
vertex ai ecosystem and selecting a
framework for how we want to train the
model providing the images and going
through the training cycle
once the training's done we need to
review the accuracy to make sure that we
don't have loss make sure we're
identifying items correctly and as part
of that you section the data set into
a section for testing a section for
validation and then a section for
training
and by identifying the accuracy across
these different segments of your data
you can understand how well the model
performed during the training cycle
once you've identified the training is
complete now we can deploy the model and
have it served through vertex ai in a
one-click deploy and this piece is where
we're now landing new predictions on
unseen data to understand how the model
is performing in real world conditions
and leveraging vertex ai as the
underlying resource
once we understand how
the model is performing we can identify
low confidence predictions and improve
on the model augmenting the data set and
it's this retraining that helps us
improve the model over time so we have
more robust models in production that
was an amazing demo now my favorite part
of the show how does this actually work
now let's say i'm a customer deploying
the solution take me behind the scenes
into the request flow and the
architecture great this is also my
favorite part
so as a customer we go to google cloud
marketplace and we can enable our
marketplace solution with a one click
deploy through some configuration we now
have the
api platform from plain sight deployed
within a customer's network
at this point we deploy a variety of
containers but specifically i want to
talk about the dashboard and our api
these are the entry points into the
application
business users will consume the
dashboard in a no code ui
that then
consumes the api
everything is done through the api so as
a developer you could access just the
api yourself to enable all of these
different features and functions of the
platform
these then are put behind a load
balancer to make sure that we're able to
scale consumption of the api as well as
users that are using the platform for
labeling building models deploying
services a variety of different features
and tasks once we have the dashboard
stood up and it's behind a load balancer
we're now starting to collect data right
and we talked about how we have to get
images into the ecosystem and this is
through the ingestion pipeline where
adding images into google cloud bucket
or connecting up an existing google
cloud storage location into the
application to leverage our existing
storage that we have within the network
this then allows us to have a little bit
of introspection over the data set right
we now get into this piece around
labeling and labeling is really
providing that context that we talked
about earlier but
technically it's really associating a
relationship to an image so you have the
underlying resource where an image is
stored in a bucket but you also have to
store the type of label where it's at on
the image what's the resolution of the
image these sort of metadata and
criteria are the relationship data that
we store in cloud sql and again this is
all within the ecosystem so the users
and clients have this available to them
within their network and then from the
vertex ai position we're really
leveraging vertex ai to help us with
model training as well as model serving
these are the two pieces the core pieces
of vertex ai that are leveraged by the
plain side ai platform that enable us to
have that con that uh templated
container and use those services in a
scaled fashion with the security
provided through the google ecosystem
we'll get into vertex ai in just a
second but i'm curious about the memory
store usage as well what are you using
memory store for
so memory store is really around
having access to files and images in a
fashion that's cached throughout the
ecosystem so memory store keeps our
images in a hot or ready state and
allows us to be able to use those
through either the api or the load
balancer as we need them wow great okay
so coming back to vertex ai we launched
vertex ai at io this year and i've
created a series of videos on it so if
you're interested in checking them out
they're linked below
carlos i am really excited to learn more
about how plain sight is leveraging
vertex ai we're very happy to be using
vertex ai specifically the pieces around
training and
deployment to allow
our platform to leverage the underlying
infrastructure that's available there in
google cloud but really we're deploying
custom containers and these custom
containers are templated from the plain
site perspective so where we can just
update the model file within the
training container and the same model
file within the serving container to
enable a variety of different use cases
custom use cases to be deployed within
the platform
yeah i can't agree more vertex ai custom
containers is such a great way to
templatize a process like this and also
to shield away the complexity from the
external user
now what happens when a user starts to
build the model
through the plain sight no code
dashboard users are able to add images
and videos from their own workstations
or connect up an existing gcs folder
location and use that within their
ecosystem at that point we really need
to understand the relationship between
those images and files that are being
used in the plain sight platform and
this is where relational data is created
through this process of identifying the
underlying resource and providing a
human readable
association for that data we relate the
two and this is where cloud sql really
comes in handy from a managed services
perspective because it's the same in
every deployment
and now we have a relationship in a
matter that the organization can retain
that data as well
remember all of this is really stored in
the customer's network soon after the
raw files are added to the data set
users provide labeling of those files
within our ecosystem and this is that
way for humans to provide context to the
model during the labeling process think
of this part around telling the computer
what you're really interested in and
discovering in these new images
yeah and in a realistic scenario this
data is going to continue to grow so how
is the labeling handled with the growing
data set
yeah great question and uh from your
experience and ours its data sets always
continue to grow there uh they never get
smaller because you always need
representative data for additional use
cases or environments that were
previously trained on and as these sets
get larger and larger it takes
additional resources to be able to
curate these data sets properly so human
annotation labeling workforce is a
collaborative environment where people
can work together to be able to curate
data sets to ensure that there's
quality within the data set there's
representation so we don't build a bias
in the data set at all and this really
leads to a path of
having a more accurate data set that
enables better prediction once we get
into the deployed instance of the model
but from the collaborative perspective
once the labels have been reviewed and
approved this is where we lock the data
set and have our version control and
this really is the way to provide a
point in time look at the underlying
data used by the model in training and
in deployment it's it's a view into
what's called explainable ai where
introspection into the model and the
data set it's possible so we can see
how we're representing the predictions
whether we're overly biased for one
specific class if we need to add
additional data or the underlying
data set is biased in a given way right
we don't want we want our model to
perform in a robust manner and to do so
the data set really has to be
representative
yeah and
that representation and explainable ai
and the ability to do that is just so
important and it's going to continue to
grow
to have better models so having that is
great and now we know that we have the
data that's ingested we have it labeled
so the next step is training it how does
training work in plain sight so with the
plain sight platform training is a very
straightforward process for the user
it's a one button click that packages up
the location of the data with its
relational data that we have it has our
labels that we previously applied and it
takes our customized container and
deploys all that into a training
environment leveraged by vertex ai and
there we can actually perform the
training with
without having to understand which
framework that we're going to use
there's a lot of sensible defaults that
can be made for business users to be
able to succeed in model training and
this is really where our smart ml
feature is leveraged to its t when we go
to deploy these no code model training
cycles and that sticks out to me the no
code feature right the one click uh
training the model and the user really
does not have to even know or define
the training process which is the
containers that you're deploying behind
the scenes and you're just leveraging
vertex ai to do that and training
but the user is shielded away from that
which is beautiful because they can just
focus on their data and then making sure
they get an output which is the model
now
take me behind the scenes of what
happens when they click on that train
button this is a powerful feature that
we have around the smart ml it's um a
way that actually identifies the
appropriate framework that's required
because we have all the context of what
the user has been telling us throughout
the whole process and kicks off the
training function for the user
but it's not just being able to take
those logical defaults it's really about
monitoring the training while the word
training in vertex ai and identifying
you know when's enough to train because
training training today is a very
iterative approach where we train for an
hour see how we work we trade for five
hours and see how see how the model
worked during training but really we can
budget an amount of time and then
smartml will stop the training when we
have achieved a productionalized
accuracy and a
model performance across the data set
that we're training on and this is
really part of the features where we're
saving additional costs with underlying
infrastructure
by not continuing to train past when we
need to as well as understanding models
and accuracy while we are doing the
training it saves a lot of time to
have introspection within the training
prior to getting into your serving
environment or when the model is being
used in production
at this point
when the model is ready to be deployed
and
smart ml will tell us when the model is
ready to be deployed
these the model file is then added into
the plain sight custom serving container
that we deploy
and this container is again with the one
button pushed through our
low code
platform this one button push enables
that customized container to be served
through vertex ai's prediction
and our prediction container is a bit
different than the training container
because the prediction container we're
now interested in unseen predictions and
want to understand what the confidence
score is with that unseen prediction
so this this container has integrations
that make it really easy for
organizations to
add those predictions into a bi workflow
or an anomaly detection workflow that's
required in some cases where we're
structuring the data from video in a way
where it now can be consumed by
traditional models that are non-computer
vision models
this this prediction container is
enabled to do that by pub sub every
prediction container from our
perspective when we deploy a custom
container serves up a
a message into the pub sub where now a
developer or a bi integration um
a bi integration can now consume that
message and leverage that within a
larger ecosystem
that's amazing because once the
predictions are being made they're going
to be made by different applications not
just one application so having that
connector with pub sub as um as a
messaging bus in between is just this
powerful because now any number of
applications can just subscribe to that
model and and get the get the
predictions now i see the benefit of
marketplace deployment here because as a
user i love that all the components of
this workflow are deployed in my own
project and i have access to it i can
look at it
could you please highlight why you chose
google cloud marketplace to be that
delivery mechanism for this service i
think ahead of that it's important to
understand the choice for google as a
hosting provider for us and and why we
chose google google is very forward with
their approach to ai and their ability
to
build features that are enabling these
use cases that we're talking about and
innovate in an innovative fashion and
marketplace was a natural progression
for us we wanted to be able to meet the
google customers in an environment where
they're currently hosted and leverage
their entire ecosystem through a very
quick and easy marketplace deploy
and as our customers adopt vision ai
solutions we wanted to be able to grow
with them as well so we're leveraging
the customers infrastructure we have
where security and privacy have already
been built in their data stores
where
a lot of cases customers don't want
their data to leave their environment
especially for sensitive information
where there's a lot of privacy concerns
in these cases we need to meet the
customer in their data center or in
their
cloud environment
additionally we're controlling egress
costs we don't want to have to send data
out of the ecosystem because frankly it
costs more to send it out if we can
process it all within the ecosystem we
get to save on egress costs
and by having all the data stored within
your ecosystem
we do not create a vendor lock-in
environment where customers feel that
they're required to use google cloud or
plain sight it's their data it's their
private network
and this is this is really part of the
key where we want to be able to allow
customers to innovate in new ways for
vision ai solutions within their
environment this is so great to hear i
can definitely see the architecture
obviously complicated and
um i just want to know what's the secret
of success here so the secret to the
success here is really a collaboration
and it's the do it team thomas bush
helping us form our
you know how do we go to market with
this solution how do we
leverage the best we can the
relationship that we have to deploy from
a technical perspective and providing
that guidance
as well as the google cloud team these
guys have been rock stars throughout the
entire process and kyle grimstad our
account manager
is uh the leader of the rock band over
there and he helps us navigate a lot of
the challenging situations that we have
and it's our own team our internal teams
really work hard in making sure that we
enable the product vision in our product
and have that user experience that is a
delightful experience that's easy and
fast
yeah like like everybody always says it
takes a village to create anything and
that's what you just described there um
awesome well congratulations on that
accomplishment uh thank you carlos for
joining us today coming on the show and
sharing what plainside does
priyanka thanks a lot for your time i
appreciate the opportunity being able to
be a google cloud build partner and
showcase part of our solution around
vision ai and how we're able to
accelerate innovation within enterprises
all right so we learned a lot today
about a no code vision ai solution that
you can easily spin up by a single click
on google cloud marketplace giving you
full control over your data resources
and billing within your google cloud
project if you want to give it a try or
learn more check out the links below
want to see more real life architectures
like this give us a like and subscribe
to get notified
you